DRONE FAR LESS SOPHISTICATED
THAN THE AMERICAN REAPER AND
HAWK.
CNN'S IVAN WATSON HAS MORE.
>> Reporter: UKRAINIAN MILITARY
FOOTAGE OF A DRONE STRIKE ON A
RUSSIAN ROCKET LAUNCHER.
THE BLOODY WAR BETWEEN RUSSIA
AND UKRAINE IS BEING FOUGHT ON
THE GROUND AND IN THE SKY USING
DRONES AND UNMANNED AERIAL
VEHICLES OR UAVs, SOME OF WHICH
WERE NEVER INTENDED FOR MILITARY
USE.
THIS IS ONE OF THE WEAPONS IN
THIS WAR, A DRONE THAT COULD FLY
FAR BEHIND THE FRONT LINES
CARRYING A POWERFUL BOMB RIGGED
TO HURL DEADLY PIECES OF
SHRAPNEL LIKE THIS.
UKRAINE'S TERRITORIAL DEFENSE
GAVE CNN AN EXCLUSIVE LOOK OF
WHAT'S LEFT OF A WEAPONIZED UAV
ORIGINALLY MANUFACTURED IN
CHINA.
UKRAINE'S STATE SECURITY SERVICE
SAYS AN AGENT REPORTED THE
LAUNCH OF THE DRONE FROM RUSSIAN
OCCUPIED TERRITORY, AND TROOPS
SHOT IT DOWN AT 2:00 A.M. ON
SATURDAY.
THIS IS REMARKABLE.
THE OFFICER IS EXPLAINING THAT
HIS MEN SHOT THIS DRONE DOWN
USING RIFLES.
RIFLES.
SO THE DRONE WAS FLYING LOW.
THE DRONE WAS FLYING LOW AND
VISIBLE TO THE NAKED EYE, HE
TELLS ME.
THIS IS WHERE THE BOMB LANDED,
THE EXPLOSIVE DEVICE ON THE
DRONE.
TROOPS RIGGED THE UNEXPLODED 20
KILOGRAM BOMB WITH EXPLOSIVES
AND THEN SPRINTED FOR COVER.
OFFICERS IDENTIFIED THE DRONE AS
A MOOGEN 5 WHICH THE
MANUFACTURER MOOGEN LIMITED,
ALSO CONFIRMED TO CNN.
THE COMPANY IS BASED IN CHINA,
DESIGNING UAV AIR FRAMES FOR
ACTIVITIES LIKE FOREST FIRE
PREVENTION AND AGRICULTURE.
THE DRONES HAVE BEEN AVAILABLE
FOR SALE ON CHINESE ONLINE
MARKETPLACES LIKE ALIBABA FOR UP
TO AROUND $15,000 PROMPTING SOME
TECH BLOGGERS TO GIVE IT THE
NICKNAME THE ALIBABA DRONE.
IT CONDEMNS ANY DRONES FOR USE
ON THE PATALFIELD ADDING THE
COMPANY CEASED TO ACCEPT ORDERS
FROM BOTH RUSSIA AND UKRAINE
SINCE THE START OF THE YEAR.
BUT THEY DISPLAYED IMAGES WHAT
IS ALSO A MOOGEN 5.
CHRIS JONES CALLS THESE
MATERIALIZED UAVs DUMB BOMBS.
>> THIS PARTICULAR DRONE WE'VE
BEEN LOOKING AT WOULD BE MUCH
MORE EFFECTIVE IF IT HAD A
DECENT CAMERA IN IT.
>> Reporter: THE FORMER BRITISH
OFFICER WHO SPECIALIZED IN DRONE
WARFARE SAYS HE EXPECTED MORE
FROM A MILITARY SUPER POWER LI